hails of guys my name is a channel
welcome to the next episode of the
series a mini series so last time we
took a look at some basic stuff such as
how binary works and how bit shifting
and how all of the bitwise operators
that we have work in fact his little
table for you guys and if you missed
that video there'll be a like an
annotation on the screen right now
that'll take you guys to it because it's
very important that you watch that video
so that you understand how this video
works because today we're going to be
covering some of the basic things that
will actually be using in order to to
achieve isolation okay so we're actually
going to start writing our library today
so we had this little binary kind of
project I'm just going to close that for
now and I'm going to make a new Java
project and that binary will probably
remain as our kind of test project but
I'll call this one just serialization
that's pretty boring isn't it we'll call
it rain cloud civilization because rain
cloud as I discussed is going to be the
game programming networking API so rain
cloud serialization just like that cool
binary is going to like I'm actually
going to keep this project open it's
going to be our test so the way that
this is going to work is that I'm going
to just this is gonna be purely on API
so we'll go convert the Shonan to rain
cloud something like that dot i don't
know dot sterilization and then we'll
have like a sterilization writer which
is what we're actually going to do today
we're going to work on this realization
writer so this is i'll explain what this
is more or less than a minute here but
we're just making a new class in the
source directory here and there we go
throw that in writer right and then
what's gonna happen as this is actually
going to so if we had something like a
few methods here which we will in a
menace such as public static well when
you Java update cool
na now they're public static int or poly
static void test like we just had a
method here what we're gonna do is click
on this binary project which is going to
be out like testbench sandbox kind of
deal if you go to Java build path and
then projects you can actually add
projects in your workspace to this
project and that's
kind of the same thing as you would do
in Visual Studio when you have
references to other projects basically
that lets us still keep these guys
separate because this shouldn't have
like any kind of main method or anything
because it's just a pure library we
don't have to keep we're exploiting it
as like a jar file or something like
that or have our test code inside this
project we can kind of take it out here
now for this case again you might argue
that's probably not that necessary but
remember in int like there's no reason
not to do it and in something like game
programming we will be having rain
clouds a separate library in the same
workspace so we'll do something like
that but anyway there we have it so now
you can see if I were to do
sterilization writer at work dot you
know test for example and that would
work fine even though that this is you
know it's a different project okay cool
so anyway without further ado let's get
into this stuff so it's a pretty long
namespace by the way but anyway let's
get into this stuff so this video we're
going to talk about starting our
serialization writer so what is our
sterilization writer
well this class is essentially
responsible for interacting with pretty
much the lowest level of operations okay
so what this is going to do is it's
going to ideally actually write our
format alright hence the name writer so
to kind of give you guys a more
high-level overview we give this
realization writer a bunch of bytes or a
bunch of values usually it'll be like
maybe a string or an integer or
something like that and it will actually
write it into a byte array for us okay
it might not be responsible for the
actual input output for files or network
streams it shouldn't do that stuff but
it's just going to basically write out
our data into a massive byte array and
that's kind of the idea right and it'll
probably also carry bits of the file
format with it as well so let's begin
writing this thing so one of the first
things I want to start off with is just
a few basic constants that will define
certain
and of determined aspects of our file
format so for example we'll have a
public static final of byte array called
I don't really want to call this header
but we'll call it head off right and
this will be a two byte array which
essentially if we go back to our format
here for a minute you will see that I
actually said that the first thing we
see here is the two characters RC
okay raincloud so to do that easy way to
do that is just type in RC as a string
and then hit the dot and then get bytes
all right
simple as that this will of course be a
string so this is the same thing as
doing something like that I don't know
why you would do that but you can do
that and yeah okay sneeze right there
anyway so we call this our CEO that we
will extract the bus from it and this
should basically have two bytes for us R
and C okay cool so that's pretty simple
we'll also have I think we decided to
have something like a short sort of too
bad version here so we'll have something
like we can just have this as a short
and I'll call it version and for now
we'll just drop with something like one
doesn't really matter this is as short
as what else is actually this big you'll
probably see me write
values as they appear in hexadecimal so
in other words I'll take up the entire
length of a short so instead of writing
that or that which of course would be
the same thing I would write that just
because when I'm reading this this would
make more sense because this is what
it's actually going to look like okay
another thing that I feel is important
but we'll probably get to this more when
we actually have a product to look at
right so once we actually start writing
out the bytes and I can bring them up in
like a hex editor and show you guys is
nd in this okay so this is what's called
big-endian the reason it's called and
and endianness refers to the order of
bytes so what I mean by that is you can
basically if you have two bytes to
represent like we do here we've got with
your let's see we've got zero
and we've got one right there yet there
are true layouts in memory that we could
use for this we could either use
little-endian which would mean that
essentially the most significant parts
contain the beginning of our stream okay
so that would look like this
so essentially memory wise it would look
like that which is a bit weird yes
personally I don't like that or
big-endian which is kind of the other
way around
all right so usually when you're looking
at memory you'll be looking at begin
diem all right and it's just a bit
easier for us to deal with like that and
it kind of makes more sense to me
because if you're dealing with decimal
as well you wouldn't have something like
if you were writing something like five
and you were using a bunch of zeros you
would typically do something like this
and not that that would look a bit weird
okay so since we kind of read this byte
from left to right I feel like it's
probably good to read the whole thing
left to right a lot of people feel a
little endian that I don't understand
why honestly ending this is a very
confusing topic by the way you'll always
confuse the two but for all intents and
purposes right now we'll be writing this
in big endian I don't even think you
need to know that okay like I don't
think there'll be a point at which were
like oh my goodness we need to convert
from one endianness to another because I
just don't think that will happen
especially because we're dealing with a
single platform here and we're not going
to be certainly dealing with stuff like
console CPUs or anything that might
function in a different way and require
the memory to be stored differently so
that should be totally fine since we are
developing for PC ok cool so that's
pretty much that's probably gonna be
about it now in fact if I just look over
here so we've got flags yeah we might as
well want stuff like flags and then
we'll move on to the name stuff that
name someone really happened so flags is
again something that I don't actually
were right here but typically we would
have something like a bite for Flags the
reason I want to write here is because
it's not going to become credibly
defined I'm not going to just write it
like that straight away because this
will actually depend on settings that we
set whereas this stuff is not something
that we should be able to set
client-side because this has not
to do with the data the flags will have
something to do with the actual data
that we write out for example is it
compressed is it part of a series all
that kind of stuff right but that stuff
that we set based on the data that we
write
whereas version and header are kind of
concrete things that really should never
be changed so version really only should
get changed once we actually increment a
version okay in fact I might change the
version to be something like that which
would I would kind of treat that like
one byte for the major version one byte
for the minor version so this is like
1.0 and just stick with that until we
need to make minor revisions or major
revisions or something like that okay
cool so there we go so let's talk about
how we can write bytes out and how we
will be writing bytes out in fact so the
way that this is going to work is
actually really simple we're going to
have methods such as they're going to
all return inches we're gonna have
methods such as set bytes okay hold
right by its flew right you could call
us whatever you want what I'm just gonna
call it yeah we call it right why not it
is this utilization writer will have a
destination all right so this is the
byte array as to which into which we're
actually going to write these bytes into
we're going to have a pointer which is
an integer now this points this is
essentially the index of this
destination array where we want to start
writing to okay and then finally we have
a value so let's for example say the
world going to be writing on one bite
okay so what this would look like is
pretty simple we would access the
pointer index inside the destination
array okay we would increment it after
we're done so yeah I would write it like
that for now and we would set of course
that equal to value so this is basically
the same thing as writing that I'm just
kind of saving a line and then finally
of course we need to return point of the
reason we're incrementing the pointer is
because we're saying we've written by it
and this is now the new pointer into
that array into where we where we've
well
- right and this will make sense want to
show you the usage in a minute but
that's kind of the idea okay so of
course instead of taking up an extra
line here we can just do something like
pointer plus plus this will write the so
if pointer was zero when we fed it in
this will write the value to destination
in index zero then change pointer to one
and then return pointer so you could
also write this as that for example
because that is a pre increment rather
than post increment which is what we had
over here okay anyway we'll deal with
something like this because this will
make more sense once when you add other
things like shots so writing on a byte
is very simple okay if we take a look at
what this might look like in our main
thing one thing I'm going to do quickly
is I'm actually going to import static
the comb the Cherno civilization
civilization writer dot asterisks here
alright just so that we don't have to
keep writing a sterilization right a dot
right bytes we can just write right
bytes as you can see so if we had a byte
array called data and we set it equal to
let's just say we want to deal with 680
bytes for now and then we had a bias
that inert let's say we wanted to ride
out this header which will actually deal
with because we don't have that yet but
let's just say we had a bytes number and
I'll set it equal to like 10 or
something right we want you to write
that out we simply call write bytes the
destination would be data the pointer in
this case would be 0 and the value would
be number okay done and that will
actually set the first index of course
of data to be that number which is 10
now the reason the pointer exists is for
this we can set this equal to pointer
and then what we can do is actually just
keep writing that number or something
like that so I can keep doing this and
what will happen is if we were actually
to look at the bytearray so we might
make a method here called static void
print print bytes alright and it will
take in a byte array whoops
so data it was taken battery and it
would essentially I think what we'll do
from now is we'll just go through every
index every bite in there and we'll just
probably print it as a system out of
print Apple printed as a hexadecimal
digit here
in fact yeah I will write a decent thing
here we'll we'll say that we'll just
print it with a space at this point and
that should be enough for now because I
don't think we've got a massive
situation going on but if we do
something like this and we write it out
so print bytes
Donna all right
oh sorry make sure you feed pointer into
each of these obviously because
otherwise it's not going to do anything
so if we run that I'm gonna get a crash
apparently legal format conversion
exception well this is the first thing
I've ever seen
all right of course we need data I okay
otherwise writing that whole array okay
there you go so this looks pretty
terrible let's write like 0x at the
front or something okay there we go this
looks a bit better so you can see how
our bytes work right now so a of course
is 10 and then you can see that what
it's done is it's written 10 a bunch of
times so we've decided to write a 1 2 3
4 5 6 times so you can see there are 6
days over here and then whatever we
write to the next one for example write
the number let's just say 8 which will
just be H in hexadecimal I need to cut
that to the bias you'll see that it says
8 over here okay so we've got a pretty
automated way where we can just keep
writing bytes in in a sequence okay and
that's very important because you can
imagine we want to kind of we want it to
look nice okay instead of having to kind
of maintain an index every time we can
just set a pointer and it will do it
automatically now in this case it's
actually not that difficult we could
have easily rewritten this as something
like data we've made a inter pointer
over here equal to something like
zero as it was before and then we could
have done something like point of plus
plus equals number and then we could
just on that and yes that is in this
case that might actually look nicer than
what we had okay
the problem arises when we want to write
stuff that aren't that aren't simple
bytes so exactly for example if we
wanted to write a short out so short
value okay
we come to a problem because a short
takes up two bytes as you know so how do
we write two bytes into this well
obviously it's going to take up two in
two indices in this destination array
that's the first thing now from what you
learned last episode we know that we
have the ability to extract certain
bites out of integers for example we
looked at last time but obviously any
data type really so what we need to do
here is we need to simply extract two
bytes out of here so a short of course
in memory is going to look like
something again if we had like just the
number one it would look like something
it would look something like this right
so would take up two bytes and it would
really just look like that okay so that
being said we need to extract that first
bit and write it out first okay so we're
going be endian so we're writing that
bit out first and then we're adding out
little endian I guess part okay not
Indian but just a little partner okay
we're going to try that second thing up
second so we need to extract this now
biasing bit masking and bit shifting
that is obviously going to be a piece of
cake so what we'll do here is we will
say that the value what we'll do is we
will shift the value by H so this is
actually kind of the reverse of what we
did in the yesterday's thing R it'll
work the same way so we can either shift
the value this way let me just quickly
cause that to apply as well there we go
okay so we could either do this or a
different way of writing the exact same
statement would be like this let me just
grab that whole chunk
and I'm not sure why you would do it
that way I think that that's a bit messy
because if we did choose to do it this
way if that didn't exist then a next
chunk would kind of be that and this
kind of starts looking weird where you
have different lengths for this so
there's it's gonna do the same thing
really I just think that this one looks
nice that's why I'm doing it so then
obviously the second one is just going
to really be value and FF but just to
kind of make it look nice and aligned
good I'm just going to shift it by zero
places which is gonna do absolutely
nothing right but it kind of looks nice
cool there we go so now you can see
we've implemented pointer twice okay and
we've written out a short which is
pretty cool but if we didn't have that
that would look a bit different over
here so if we had something like a short
number and we wanted to do this first of
all we need this weird bit masking but
also we we'd need to increment pointer
by two and then this just starts looking
very weird okay so that's why this whole
technique is really really good cool so
to make that work now we just need to do
something like right by its destination
will be data pointer will be 0 in this
case value will be number all right and
then I can just write that same 10 thing
out a bunch of times
replacing pointer over here okay and if
I were to print the bytes so we're gonna
have enough space for that yes we should
then it's going to look something like
this so you can see we have the 0 and
then a then 0 and a and 0 and a etc all
right so let's look at something above a
value that we can store in one bite so
for example let's just try and do the
value 10 thousands I've ever my
programming calculator here which is
just the normal calculator set to the
programmer mode which you can do by
clicking on the program here or all
three
so I've punched in the value 10,000 and
you can see that in hex that looks like
27 10 all right cool so this is the
value that I'm expecting to see let's
punch that in so we'll go ten thousands
all right and if we run this and we
print it you can see we see 27 10 all
right and you can see kind of how that
works all right so it's pretty simple it
works really well I think and this is
kind of the most efficient way that I've
discovered so far in doing this okay
because it's hips just work well and not
take up too much code and look really
clean as far as this goes all right I'm
going to do one more today we're going
to cover more stuff next time but we're
just going to do the same thing here for
an integer okay and you can probably
guess what this is and we might as well
do it along as well but this is just
going to be more of the same except
we'll have shifting by 16 and by 24 over
here and then for a long that's going to
be a big one long of course takes up 8
bytes so it's going to just keep going
up really by increments of 8 so 30 to 40
and 48 no that's wrong because I missed
one 56 should be our last one okay there
you go so that would be our long and
that's it so for if I again decide to
print this as an integer and we do the
same 10,000 or something like that it's
going to actually have just enough space
there by the way sixteen four times four
of course is 16 but um for being the
size of an integer and for being the
amount of times we wrote it but there
you go you can see that the first of
course two bytes here are going to be
zero and then we're going to have that
27 10 that we did for the shorts which
is really takes up more space we could
have written this out as short but there
we go that's an example there cool there
we go and a long of course will kind of
look the same I'll print out two Long's
because I can't do any more than that
we're really just gonna get more zeroes
in this case okay a lot of zeros here
but you can see that we could print
something like long the max value and
there we go okay now it doesn't go all
the way to ffs because it stills
negative values as well which is why
that's
stored like that so something like min
value would be zero with a to zero
meaning that it's is negative anyway
what I got to deal with how this
actually works but um you can see that
we've written we've got the ability now
to write a bunch of eyes to a
destination all right cool the other
important thing that we'll probably just
talk more about this next time but we'll
deal with doubles and floats next time
which is going to be a bit different one
oh and we'll also talk about why I've
chosen this method and not stuff like
byte buffer and we'll probably compare
more my comparison performance
characteristics of different ways you
can write bias but this is as far as I
know this is the fastest way to do it
but that having said that I've done like
zero testing and this is just kind of my
my assumption alright anyway I hope you
guys enjoy this video if you did please
hit the like button if you really like
my videos and would like to see more
then you can support me on patreon
dot-com 4/2 Cherno if you donate a
certain amount per month you get access
to pretty cool features such as the
entire source code for game programming
via the private github repository I'll
probably start adding more private
github repositories in the future as
well with other projects such as 3d game
programming so stay tuned for that
because I've got some news coming out
pretty soon about that which is pretty
exciting and if you like talking to
people about programming and game
development then you could definitely
going to want to join up on the select
up the turtlecom so this is basically
like a team real-time messaging platform
in which you can talk with all the
different people in the shadow community
as well as me I'm very frequently on
there so anyway if you guys enjoy this
video hit the like button and next time
we should have some pretty exciting
times continuing with this civilization
stuff goodbye